m
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour c'est une information sportive
qui fait le titre de notre journal
aujourd'hui
et il ne s'agit pas d'une victoire
d'eddy merckx au moins pour le moment
l'équipe de france d'athlétisme mène
devant celle des états unis
et hier soir à colombes les français ont
remporté sept victoires et les
américains 3 ces performances françaises
sont de très bonne tenue puisque
plusieurs records de france ont été
battus et on a même frisé des records du
bien sûr le match n'est pas terminé mais
d'ores et déjà on peut dire que c'est
une bonne surprise que nous ont offert
hier soir les athlètes français surtout
dans le 100 mètres le 4 x 100 m le poids
et le 400 m est close mais dieu
assistaient à cette rencontre
à tout seigneur tout honneur le nouveau
capitaine de l'équipe de france pierre
colnard allait se distinguer au 2e essai
19 mètres soixante dix nouveaux records
de france et du même coup les deux
américain derrière lui
la première course et ss du 400 m e et
qui opposait le nouveau recordman du
monde man à jean claude mallet en blanc
le français allait remporter la victoire
en réalisant 48 secondes 6/10 troisième
performance de tous les temps au 100 m
ses croquettes est parti très rapidement
après soixante mètres de course sarthe
heures va prendre le meilleur sur lui
ainsi que fenouil premiers et troisièmes
les 20000 spectateurs n'en croyaient pas
leurs yeux
le relais 4 x 100 m la technique des
français vatel avoir raison de la classe
des américains
certes heures confirme son excellent
s'en remettra sa croquette si vous gagne
remonte un petit peu bourne
celui ci va transmettre dans de bonnes
conditions à fenouil la lutte va être
terrible et regardez bien après ce
relais des américains suivaient le
nouveau c'est là que les états unis vont
perdre la course carte urner va partir
arrêtés ils n'avaient pas attendu assez
longtemps art fun fun où il donne à
mesquer lens et metz va franchir en
vainqueur la ligne d'arrivée
au saut en longueur panique gagne avec
huit mètres au 05 tour est deuxième avec
7 m 82 et 1 centimètres d'avancé sur
l'américain derrière lui le quatrième
set m quatre hommes au 5000 mètres
wadoux voulait faire une grande course
après être passé en 10 minutes 48
secondes 2/10 on pensait que le français
pourrait approcher le record d'europe du
nord portent le temps du 4000 mètres
étant tout à fait remarquable en fait
malgré les que le français va voir
maintenant en point de mire
wadoux effectuera les 200 derniers
mètres en 33 secondes sont en 13 minutes
28 secondes
il est à 4 dixièmes du record de france
de jazy m'évade ou a terminé fatiguée
aura-t-il récupéré pour le quinze 100 m
2 ce soir
la farce mène de six points c'est
inespéré
elle mène de six points car vilain va
gagner en 8 minutes 33 secondes le 3000
m steeples la france mène donc 2 6
points ce soir ce soir partait de bonne
heure pour aller à colon le match est
fantastique et la deuxième journée doit
être favorable aux américains mais tout
de même il serait dommage que vous ne
soyez pas à colombes à 20h15 pour le
début de la réunion ici vilain qui
termine au vainqueur bien sûr sont 3000
m steeples sont en 8 minutes 33 secondes
ditex euros sera 3e
et bien claude médias vous l'a dit je
pense que c'est ce soir qu'il faudra
vraiment à les encourager à colombes si
vous pouvez venir bien sûr les athlètes
français un beau match en perspective et
nous en aurons terminé pour le sport
quand je vous aurais dit qu'au tour de
force
eddy merckx est en excellente santé et
qu'il a pris le départ pour l'étape de
montagne grenoble gap
voyons maintenant les autres points
importants de l'actualité
le budget de la france pour 1971 reste
aujourd'hui en bonne place hier le
conseil des ministres examine est le
premier volet de ce budget concernant
les dépenses et c'est en septembre après
étude du dossier que l'on connaîtra les
taux d'augmentation exact attribuées aux
différents ministères mais on sait déjà
qu'il n'y aura pas d'impôt nouveau cette
année pour le contribuable français
françois henri de virieu vous avez
rencontré le principal responsable de ce
budget le ministre des finances monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing et hier vous
étiez bien entendu à la sortie du
conseil des ministres
oui il ya dans la première chose qu'il
faut dire je crois c'est que ce conseil
des ministres d'hier n'a pas pris de
véritables décisions il a simplement
fixer l'ordre de grandeur des dépenses
de l'état pour l'année 1971 si monsieur
pompidou avait écouté les doléances de
tous ces ministres dépensiers
il aurait fallu que le budget de 1971
soit supérieur nous vous l'avons dit
hier de 14 % à celui de 1960 c'est
beaucoup trop
c'est beaucoup trop il aurait fallu
fixer à 182 milliards de francs or vous
l'avez dit le gouvernement ne veut pas
augmenter les impôts des français donc
il n'y a qu'une solution il faut freiner
les dépenses car si le train de vie de
l'état ne dépasse pas l'augmentation de
la richesse de la france alors il n'y a
pas besoin de créer de nouveaux impôts
tout au moins deux nouveaux impôts
nationaux parce que vous savez que les
impôts locaux c'est une autre histoire
il augmente très vite ces dernières
années dans tout le problème donc pour
le conseil des ministres d'hier
consistait à essayer de prévoir de
combien la richesse de la france va
s'accroître en 1971 monsieur giscard
d'estaing au début des travaux de
préparation du budget avait dit tablons
donc sur une base de 7 %
et hier en conseil des ministres le
gouvernement a changé d'avis notamment
sur le conseil du président de la
république et finalement on a estimé que
l'accroissement de la richesse nationale
serait compris à peu près entre 8 et 9%
et par conséquent les ministres seront
autorisés à dépenser 8 à 9% de d'argent
de plus comme une ascension d aimer ce
pourcentage d'augmentation ne sera pas
répartie
également sur tous les ministères il y a
donc des secteurs privilégiés peut-être
oui il y en aura trois si vous voulez il
y aura le téléphone parce que vous savez
il marche très mal en france il y aura
les routes parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'être entretenue et qu'elles sont
utiles à l'industrialisation et il y
aura enfin les aides à la
décentralisation industrielle parce
qu'il ya trop du syna paris et dans le
nord-est de la france est passée sur le
reste du territoire
or monsieur pompidou veut que la france
devienne un grand pays industriel
pendant la durée du sixième plan c'est à
dire pendant son septennat
c'est pourquoi il a réussi à convaincre
monsieur giscard d'estaing que 7 %
d'augmentation des dépenses budgétaires
ce n'était pas assez et il a dit à
monsieur giscard d'estaing qui lui
souhaitait diminuer les impôts des
français
mieux vaudrait renoncer à diminuer ses
impôts que de rater l'équipement et
l'industrialisation du pays en s'en
tenant à 7% de progression des crédits
budgétaires bien et il y a également
commandé via lieu depuis hier une
affaire qui vient de rebondir et que
certains appellent déjà le scandale de
la villette le scandale des abattoirs il
sera question est fortement question je
crois de détruire les installations donc
ultra moderne de la ville est alors que
la facture s'élève déjà à un milliard de
francs lourd alors on peut se poser la
question comment at-on pu en arriver là
je crois qu'avant de dire comment on a
pu en arriver là il faut dire que il est
bien question en effet de détruire les
amateurs de la villette mais il en est
question dans des rapports d'experts
monsieur chaban delmas lui n'a pas pris
sa décision
et selon toute vraisemblance il
n'apprendra pas avant la rentrée car
c'est une affaire qui mérite réflexion
vous avez raison je crois qu'on peut
dire que c'est là la plus grave la plus
grave erreur d'équipement économique de
la france qui était fait depuis
l'avènement de la vème république
et vous avez raison la question qui se
pose c'est comment at on pu en arriver
là à une époque on dispose de même de
moyens de prévision de moyens modernes
de prévision et d' enquête
alors il était certainement nécessaire
de remplacer l'ancien abattoir et
l'ancien marché de la villette qui avait
été construit par napoléon 1er et qui
était composé d'un certain nombre d
chaudouard qui était malsain qui était
sale et et certainement il fallait les
remplacer mais on a fait on a vu trop
grand on a fait une réalisation de
prestige et le gouvernement en tout cas
a fait deux erreurs la première était
une erreur de prévision
on a surestimé la production de viande
et on a fait à la ville est un abattoir
on
la ville est un abattoir géant aux
dimensions nationales même
internationale puisqu'il pouvait traiter
il pouvait traiter à partir de 72 120
mille tonnes par an ce qui est colossal
mais en même temps qu'on laisse est ce
pour cela cet abattoir et c'est là la
deuxième erreur du gouvernement si
l'erreur de c'est un manque de courage
politique en même temps qu construit cet
abattoir géant à paris on laissait se
construire d'autres abattoirs dans des
petites localités de france en cédant à
la pression des élus locaux et le
résultat est que plus on bâtissait à la
villette et moins il est rentré
d'animaux l'espace est absurde et
dernier point je crois qu'on peut dire
que la construction était extrêmement
coûteuses à la villette car on a voulu
recourir sur place on a construit sur un
terrain qui était relativement étroit 55
ha paris ce n'est pas très grand et
comment construire sur un terrain étroit
il a fallu construire en hauteur et la
construction en hauteur ça coûte
toujours très cher alors que aux états
unis par exemple les marchés les
abattoirs sont installés à même le sol
et par conséquent coûte beaucoup moins
cher mais on pouvait quand même il ya un
moment où vous pouvez faire une marche
arrière on s'est aperçu quand même que
c'était un gouffre que c'était vraiment
une opération perdu pourquoi n'at-on pas
celle marche arrière et quand pouvait-on
le faire oui on s'en est aperçu on s'est
même aperçu au début au début de presque
début de l'opération je me souviens très
bien que monsieur françois missoffe qui
était à l'époque en 1961 secrétaire
d'état au commerce intérieur a dit la
villette c'est trop cher et la villette
ça ne servira à rien ce serait une
erreur de poursuivre ce projet alors il
ya eu une très très longue controverse à
l'intérieur du gouvernement sur ce point
et le ministre des finances a fait
remarquer que on avait déjà engagé 1
milliard 400 millions de francs anciens
dans la sphère et que ce serait une
folie de faire marche arrière
c'est donc en connaissance de cause que
le gouvernement a décidé après une
longue délibération de poursuivre le
projet est aujourd'hui la facture les
crédits engagés
ce n'est plus un milliard 400 millions
d'anciens francs cette âme il ya 400
millions de nouveaux francs 1 milliard
déjà investi 350 millions restants
investir pour achever les travaux
et pourtant il aura fallu attendre
décembre dernier pour que les
conseillers de paris tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
il avait constaté qu'il faudrait
subventionné l'abattoir pour qu'il
puisse fonctionner bon donc
en fin de compte là la décision est
attendue pour septembre pas avant la
décision officielle probablement car les
conseillers de paris ont maintenant
remis la faire au gouvernement
ils ont fait cadeau de leur terrain de
55 hectares à l'état et maintenant la
décision m messieurs sera votre avis en
tout cas les serbes at war sont enfermés
si je me fie sur le contenu du rapport
technique certainement bien merci
françois henri de virieu et pour clore
ce chapitre maintenant en bref quelques
nouvelles sociales et politiques
à orly les manutentionnaires d'air
france sont toujours en grève 22 vols
sont annulés aujourd'hui par la compet
il est à noter que depuis maintenant
près de deux mois des grèves en
débrayage est bien le trafic à orly
et quand même sérieusement cet
après-midi patrons et syndicats doivent
se rencontrer à paris pour signer un
important accord concernant la formation
professionnelle la cfdt demeure elle est
seule
réticente mais devrait être en principe
se joindre aux autres syndicats
le comité exécutif du parti radical
s'est réuni ce matin à paris et à cette
occasion un communiqué fait savoir que
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
demeure soit secrétaire général du parti
radical et ce malgré les charges
nouvelles
que vont y amener son mandat de député
pour l'information générale maintenant
ou plutôt disons pour l'information
judiciaire
l'actualité nous ramène à cette affaire
depuis eric arlette boulbès sauveur
padovani et gaston costeaux race dijeaux
l'aixois comparaissent devant les juges
et les jurés d'aix-en-provence pour le
meurtre présumé de lucie zh
vous en connaissez vous connaissez
maintenant bien la faire mais ce matin
sachez qu'il ya eu une suspension
d'audience
à la suite d'un incident incidents assez
violents entre les avocats de la défense
et un témoin un capitaine de gendarmerie
le capitaine harceler semble-t-il par
les avocats de la défense les sept
échappés
il y a une différence entre vous et moi
je ne suis pas payé pour dire ce que je
ne pense pas et les défenseurs ont alors
quitté la salle en demandant des excuses
immédiates en attendait du spectaculaire
et bien ce n'est finalement pas de l'un
des trois accusés qu'est venu le premier
incident au matin de cette seconde
journée d'audience il est toujours aussi
difficile de dire ce qu'il ya au-delà
des visages des inculpés qui ont essayé
de jouer au personnage de roman policier
revu et corrigé par pagnol dans la
grande salle des assises aux sept
employés hier à cerner la personnalité
des inculpés en particulier celle
d'arlette bulls une baisse qui semble la
plus intelligente des trois ans red bull
buzz qui dès son enfant serait vécue
dans un
de débauche elle s'est défendu hier
d'avoir monnayé ses charmes comme le
deal enquête
arlette la quarantaine venue s'est
découvert une vocation de dames de
compagnie pour vieillards esseulé
vocation récompensé certes puisque ces
vieillards souvent là couché sur leur
testament elle a nié hier avoir raté
leur mort elle a dit un âge avancé la
mort n'est pas forcément un accident ou
un crime un vieillard est même venu
témoigner qu'elle était leur providence
sans dernier protège et et le vigan de
régis que la justice qualifie de
libertin du xviiie siècle
là aussi elle soutient qu'elle était
simplement relations d'affaires avec lui
car elle voulait acheter son château la
providence ne veillait pas sur lui six
heures la gouvernance du château le 29
juillet 1969 elle est écrasée par une
idée 19 blanche
le médecin légiste est venu dire que la
blessure infligée par la voiture à lucie
zohar n'était pas mortelle elle a été
tuée parce qu'elle a été
malencontreusement projeté contre une
souche d'arbre
les inculpés sont poursuivis non pour
meurtre mais pour coups et blessures
ayant entraîné la mort sans intention de
la donner
pour les nouvelles de l'étranger
maintenant et bien peu d'informations en
ce qui concerne les deux points choses
et à dire l'indochine et le moyen-orient
au moyen-orient pourtant l'aviation
israélienne a attaqué une base de fusées
sam 2 au nord du canal de suez et pour
l'indochine les forces thaïlandaises
sont en état d' alerte dans le nord du
pays à la suite disons d'une
concentration importante de troupes viet
congs dans la riche mais en rapport avec
les affaires du vietnam
on parle encore beaucoup aujourd'hui aux
états unis des mauvais traitements
infligés à ces prisonniers viet congs et
nord-vietnamiens dans le bagne de poule
aux condors je vous rappelle que ce sont
des sénateurs américains qui ont soulevé
la sphère en réussissant à pénétrer dans
ce coup mais par ailleurs on apprenait
que les troupes sud vietnamienne avait
libéré un contingent de prisonniers viet
congs et pour cette occasion là la
presse était convoqué 86 prisonniers
nord-vietnamiens dans vingt-quatre
civils des pêcheurs détenus depuis 1965
pour avoir pénétré illégalement dans les
eaux territoriales du sud vietnam ont
donc été relâché les prisonniers ont été
embarqué mardi à bord d'une péniche de
la marine vietnamienne à destination de
la zone démilitarisée où ils ont été
débarqués libéré devant 2
durant une brève période de cessez le
feu c'est la première libération par les
voies maritimes effectué par le
gouvernement de ses gonds depuis juin
1967 la destruction du pont sur la
rivière ben rail au centre de la zone
démilitarisée interdit depuis la
libération par voie de terre nous en
arrivons maintenant pour cette édition à
des sujets moins grave est plus en
rapport peut-être avec cette actualité
que nous connaissons bien c'est à dire
les vacances le plein air le sport est
aussi les manifestations sportives qui
reviennent chaque année à pareille
époque aux apparitions des beaux jours
il en est ainsi pour le 18e tour de
france aérien des jeunes pilotes qui
débute samedi c'est une manifestation
organisée par la fédération française de
vol à moteur
le tour de france de vol à moteur dont
les jeunes pilotes est une épreuve
organisée par la fédération française de
vol à moteur pour consacrer la
régularité de l'enseignement qui est
donné dans l'isère au club depuis quand
existe t il existe depuis
cinquante-trois et pourquoi avoir fait
un tour de france
eh bien on a fait un tour de france
parce que nous avons estimé à la
fédération qu'il fallait montrer aux
jeunes ce que c'était que le voyage
aérien
ils le connaissent déjà beaucoup mieux
maintenant mais au début le mais cela
paraissait tout de même quelque chose
d'assez hasardeux exceptionnelle de
voyager en avion vers les années 53 54
comment va-t-il se dérouler sur le plan
pratique sur le plan pratique cette
année pour la première fois les jeunes
pilotes de moins de 21
son seul à bord est bien évident que
nous avons pris des précautions parce
que jusqu'à maintenant il y avait des
accompagnateurs qui étaient là
uniquement pour veiller à la sécurité et
pour éventuellement prendre l'avion en
main en cas de besoin mais nous estimons
que ce show lui menti vitae et d'autre
part j'ai fait le découpage des étapes
de telle sorte qu'en réalité on ne part
pas pour 300 km mais on part pour par
exemple 50 km de terrain intéressant se
pose est naturellement se transposer son
nez des points tournants
mais le jeune fait sa navigation sur 50
km puis arriver là l'a fait sur à notre
305 femme de sorte que il n'est jamais
plus éloignées
25 30 km dames terrain de ce cours d'eau
piloter un avion du green sens mois
depuis octobre 68 ch ouais mais 68 69
c'est donc est donc à peu près pour vous
deux finalement ce que j'ai subi un
entraînement spécial pour faire le tour
de france oui c'est à dire qu'on demande
quand même un entraînement assez
poussées en navigation est certaine
certaines épreuves plus spécial quinquin
pilotage normal on pour nous ce sera une
très bonne expérience fin du voyage
un domaine de plus tard vous avez
l'intention de le rester dans la ville
bien sûr on allait là l'intention de
rester dans l'aviation parce que quand
l'aviation est un sport c'est difficile
sur le point de vue tant son point de
vue l'argent également et c'est vraiment
parce qu'on aime ça on va en faire son
métier on veut essayer d'en faire son
métier quoi ce sont les président d'aéro
club qui engage les jeunes pilotes en
leur fournissant naturellement l'avion
sur lequel ils vont voler il faut qu'ils
aient moins de 20 ans il faut qu'ils
aient moins une vingtaine en pour les
jeunes filles
nous les aides méthode qu'à 24 ans
combien de temps est-ce que pilote nous
estimons nous estimons qu'un jeune
pilote qu'un entraînement régulier en
entraînement constant peut avoir son
brevet de pilote privé d'avion entre 50
55 heure environ et bien une expérience
de 25 heures de voyage après ce terme
doit lui permettre de faire le don de
france dans toutes les conditions
la voile maintenant la voile après le
vol à moteur vous savez qu'une très
importante compétition d'intérêt
international va se dérouler à newport
et il s'agit de la coupe america pour la
première fois la france est représentée
dans cette compétition qui oppose et 12
m de jauge internationale
mais pour l'instant ce sont les
américains tenant du titre qui se
livrent entre eux à une série
d'éliminatoires je crois je vous pensais
que nous avions des images les voici
donc nous assistons précisément au début
des éliminatoires entre les voiliers
américains voici with au relais et
intrépide et valiante et héritage de ses
quatre bateaux un seul d'entre eux le
vainqueur bien sûr rencontrera soit
l'australie si l'australie gagne sa
confrontation avec la france
ou alors rencontrera le france le bateau
dont français pour la coupe amérique
les épreuves auront lieu dès les
épreuves capitale auront lieu au mois
d'août à nous y voilà jacqueline
alexandre maintenant je pense que nous
allons un peu nous expatrier nous avons
parlé pour votre rubrique émissions
médicales ouvrit médical tout d'abord
c'est cela nous allons commencer par un
sujet sur la médecine en france on a
tendance à nous consulter son médecin
que lorsqu'on est malade alors qu'on a
réussi à donner l'habitude d'aller voir
son dentiste de façon préventive et bien
on aimerait étendre cela à la médecine
générale et ce avec le check up qui
remporte un grand succès au canada déjà
ordinateur et automatisation son tgv
gare depuis longtemps dans la médecine
au canada à montréal
le laboratoire cybernétix utilisent ces
techniques pour un domaine particulier
de la médecine celui de la médecine
préventive
c'est le check-up électronique check-up
électronique qui vous donne en deux
heures de temps
un résultat complet de votre situation
physique de pertes
quels sont les phases principales de ce
check-up électronique ici à cybernétix
est bien le patient on va lui donner un
coût et un questionnaire un
questionnaire assez complet vous pouvez
voir ici
267 question disons que ce sont des
questions qui vont lui demander
s'il a eu telle et telle maladie disons
l'histoire de sa famille et ainsi de
suite
puis après avoir répondu à toutes ses
questions
nous allons faire passer ce cet individu
ce patient à un électrocardiogramme
puis après nous allons à la chambre des
rayons x où il va avoir un radio g
ordinaire pour détection la tuberculose
puis nous allons à notre chance d'être
nommé tri c'est là qu'on va mesurer la
pression intraoculaire du patient c'est
de cette façon qu'on peut détecter le
gros con qui signe s'il n'est pas
détecté prêt à mener la complète ces
sites est là nous mesurons la fonction
vitale des poumons ou nous essayons de
détecter s'il ya des possibilités
d'emphysème du point de vue de la
personne
nous avons aussi les tests de diagrammes
division pour voir si la personne doit
porter des lunettes ainsi de suite la
pression du sang la hauteur du poids
ensuite nous faisons 21 tests
biochimiques sur le sens et après ça
nous allons faire des analyses d'urines
et en sommes tous ces tests vont être
mis sur des cartes d'ordina trice comme
vous voyez ici et ensuite nous en voyons
ça un autre ordinateur hills et nous
avons un rapport complet de l'individu
comme vous voyez ici que nous avons à
lyon au docteur le médecin traitant le
patient ne vient pas chez nous pour ce
faire dieu pour un diagnostic
le patient va uniquement chez le docteur
pour le diagnostic mais nous aidons le
patient et le docteur à ceux de ce point
de vue le patient n'a pas besoin de
courir à droite à gauche pour aller
faire des tests de rayons x au
laboratoire et deuxièmement le docteur à
tous les résultats devant lui avant
qu'il voyait le patio la machine ne
remplacera jamais le médecin pratiquant
il y a
des choses que la machine ne peut pas
faire des points de vue contact
personnel avec le patient restant à
l'étranger jacqueline cora dans son
flash philatélie tu nous parles une
montre des timbres du gabon à l'occasion
de la visite du chef de l'état en france
il y à 48 heures le président de la
république française recevait en visite
officielle le président de la république
du gabon monsieur albert bernard bongo
si nous ouvrons nos albums de timbres
aux pages consacrées à ce pays ceci nous
rappelle les premiers contacts de la
france avec cette lointaine contrée de
l'afrique équatoriale
c'est au début du 19e siècle que fut
créé un établissement français dans la
baie du gabon pour les navires chargés
de réprimer la traite des noirs dont le
gabon fut longtemps le foyer dix ans
plus tard était fondée libreville qui
recueillait les esclaves libérés
c'est à la fin de ce même 19e siècle que
la vallée de l'ogooué fut explorée par
savorgnan de brazza qui suce concilier
pacifiquement les chefs indigènes il
créa la colonie du gabon qui fait partie
de l'ouest africain puis fut liée au
congo français pour devenir en 1910 une
colonie de la es république membre de la
communauté en 1958 le gabon a acquis sa
pleine indépendance en 1960 tout en
restant membre de la nouvelle communauté
son premier président fut monsieur léon
m'ba auquel succéda l'actuel président
bongo
outre l'histoire du gabon les timbres
évoque aussi ses richesses naturelles
le bois en plus des voix précieux la
principale est censé exploiter et le
coup mais qui sert à faire des
contreplaqués les ressources minières
qui sont considérables important
gisement de manganèse dans la région de
moanda d'uranium à mounana de pétrole
aux environs de port gentil mais nous ne
saurions quitter le gabon sans évoquer
le docteur schweitzer et l'oeuvre
immense qu'il a accompli à lambaréné le
gabon une jeune république dont les
timbres reflètent les aspirations
moderne trop de timbres dans le monde
tel est le cri d'alarmé que lance nos
confrères transalpins depuis 120 ans que
leurs timbres exif la france et la
belgique ont émis chacune 2
240 timbre l'espagne a atteint le total
de 2200 46 émission la roumanie près de
3000 et la russie bat tous les records
avec près de 4000 timbre inscrit à son
catalogue
et notre confrère italien l'unita de
conclure l'incontinence est aussi une
maladie en matière postale
les femmes qui continuent de faire
couler beaucoup d'encre depuis qu'elles
sont placés à droite et non plus à
gauche des timbres rappelle les
manifestations qui viennent d'avoir lieu
en cours ou qui vont avoir lieu ce
mois-ci je ne ferais trop conseiller à
ceux d'entre vous qui s'intéresse aux
flammes postales et je sais qu'ils sont
nombreux et notamment aux jeunes loups
ouvrage de monsieur fernande et les âmes
qui était composé avec les élèves de sa
classe
il propose des conseils forte utile en
ce qui concerne la présentation le
classement la conservation des flammes
postales et aussi leur utilisation à des
fins pédagogiques sur vos agendas
vous noterez à partir d'aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 14 juillet l'exposition cosmos
et aviation qui se tiendra au palais des
expositions à béziers dans le cadre de
la grande semaine aérospatiale les 11 et
12 juillet une exposition à la maison du
tourisme à bagnères de luchon
aux mêmes dates à saint cyprien en
dordogne et enfin à grandjean dans une
petite localité de la charente maritime
dans un vieux relève post exposition de
marques postales du xviie siècle à nos
jours
à la baule vient de se dérouler le
championnat du monde des cavaliers de
concours hippiques
nous nous arrêterons donc aujourd'hui au
chapitre consacré aux timbres dédiés au
jumping je vous inviterai si vous n'avez
pas encore décidé du sujet de votre
futur thématiques à vous lancer sur le
cheval au galop pour franchir les
obstacles de l'embarras du choix
nous allons maintenant passer à la
bourse de paris avoue jean-michel 4
points et bien la bourse qui avait déjà
manifesté hier des velléités de reprise
présente aujourd'hui une meilleure
figure
beaucoup de titres sont en hausse et
récupère ainsi une partie des pertes des
séances précédentes
toutefois le volume des transactions
reste faible et l'on note surtout des
achats de la part des gros investisseurs
et des organismes de placement
comme vous pouvez vous en douter les
boursiers commente ce matin le conseil
des ministres d'hier ils vont surtout
votre nuque il n'y aurait pas d'impôt
nouveau ni de majoration des impôts
existants
cela c'est toujours une nouvelle
agréable à entendre quant à
l'augmentation de la masse budgétaire
sera d'environ 9%
elle semble indiquer que le gouvernement
choisit l'ex pense pour le reste et bien
on attend la rentrée de septembre dans
deux mois on aura plus de détails sur la
répartition des grandes masses
budgétaires
on sait déjà qu'un effort particulier
sera fait pour les télécommunications et
pour les routes
d'ailleurs les valeurs du matériel
téléphonique comme lnt vous le voyez sur
ce tableau sont très ferme aujourd'hui
mais ce qui a principalement entraîné la
reprise aujourd'hui la bourse de paris
c'est la remontée de wall street la
bourse de new york a regagné hier 13
points soit en pourcentage près de 2%
cette hausse a été surtout sensible dans
la seconde partie de la séance
lorsqu'une rumeur a circulé autour des
corbeilles de cotation cette rumeur
faisait état d'une éventuelle réduction
par le federal reserve board du taux
d'escompté qui est actuellement de 6 %
le taux de l'argent vous le savez c'est
un des points sensibles pour les
financiers aussi dès qu'on leur laisse
entrevoir une possible détente des taux
d'intérêt ils deviennent plus optimistes
mais jusqu'à présent aucune confirmation
officielle de cette rumeur n'a été
donnée en fait depuis le début de
l'année wall street évolué en dents de
scie les valeurs se replie pendant
plusieurs séances
puis brusquement une information une
rumeur amène une remontée soutenue
d'ailleurs par les investisseurs
officiel
ces derniers plutôt que d'intervenir au
jour le jour préfère concentrer leurs
efforts sur des séances bien déterminé
devant ces actions conjuguées wall
street reprend donc pendant quelques
jours et se replient de nouveau une
fausse eux ne pas s'attendre à un
changement fondamental du comportement
de la bourse américaine donc les grands
problèmes qui pèsent sur le marché
problèmes qui sont d'ordre monétaire et
économique mais aussi d'ordre social et
politique n'auront pas été résolus les
marchés financiers resteront dans
l'incertitude sur ce tableau vous voyez
les valeurs américaines qui remonte en
liaison avec la hausse de wall street
hier soir valeur française thomson gagne
francs 20 la cge 415 deuxième court et
je voudrais voir le cours de michelin
fils est encore prêt à gauche 1164 1146
hier michelin remonte depuis quelques
séances
ces deux mc doit prendre fin à
l'augmentation de capital de la société
d'une façon plus générale les émissions
qu'elle soit d'actions d'obligations
touchent à leur fin elles ont été fort
nombreuse pendant tout le premier
semestre mais maintenant il faut
attendre la rentrée pour assister à une
nouvelle opération et société en effet
n'ont aucun intérêt à lancer des
émissions pendant la période des
vacances est une époque où une bonne
partie de la clientèle est absente
toujours des hausses la compagnie
bancaire dif en cinq ans la générale des
eaux douces francs sur le marché de l'or
nous allons voir tout de suite
le lingot se replie se replie à 6400
côté hier 6415 le napoléon 57,80 la
léger gain 40 centimes sur le pin est le
cours dit hacker 158,40 je crois qu'on
perd 10 centimes un peu plus haut
voilà cent cinquante huit 38 on perd 10
centimes sans changement en pratique et
bien c'était une bourse de paris
meilleur et avoue jacqueline l'ex ans
merci télé midi et terminer nos
prochaines informations à 18h50